[Music]
morning so let's start with this how
many people in this room by show of
hands have no idea who I am
raise your hand that hurts I thought
that would be the case
first of all I've really been enjoying
you know I'm an I'm a businessman I'm an
entrepreneur
obviously I make content I write books
but I'm extremely proud that for the
last 20 years of my life from literally
the day that I left college to this
moment right now I've been operating a
business and so spending the last kind
of week or two looking at this industry
and the dynamics was interesting to me
because I think context really matters
and I think one of the things that
affords me the ability to continue to
speak at conferences which I enjoy so
much so thank you for having me is that
I don't have a canned speech I have
things I believe in but I think the
context matters and I was excited
digging into this world because one as I
was digging in I realized a couple of my
friends were in it so I was able to get
under the hood a little bit more and -
this is a perfect cliche example of an
industry and I know there's multiple
parties and the chain in this room and
I'll try to address both or all three
where I have empathy to why the majority
of people don't think or fully
understand what the impact of a Facebook
or an Instagram or snapchat mean to them
in a business world and as you can
imagine for me that's super exciting
because that means literally all I have
to do is over the course of the next
hour articulate in business terms and
create the emotion to the action of
literally just one or two individuals in
this entire conference to actually make
an impact I think what's most
fascinating for me is industries you
know look if you sell sneakers to 20
year-olds I think it makes sense that
Instagram or Facebook matter when you're
in a b2b dynamic and trying to win big
accounts or trying to become a supplier
to a big organization it
comes less obvious however then it's
funny I get to see Mickey cloud here who
runs our Chattanooga office when I
looked at him I'm thinking back to the
greatest successes at Boehner media over
the last six years and when I think
about our biggest financial impact that
has been far more than General
Electric's and ESA peas and the b2b
businesses than it has been the
Budweiser's or the Pepsi's because as a
lot of you know you know when you play
b2b and I'm in the b2b business now all
it takes is one account for it to start
getting really interesting and so
because so many of you don't know who I
am I'm gonna give you a little bit of my
origin story because it's gonna give you
a lot of ammo to actually make the leap
that I hope that you consider I was born
in Belarus in the former Soviet Union I
came to the US when I was three we lived
a very humble beginning as you can
imagine the economy wasn't super great
we didn't speak English we had a hundred
bucks I lived with seven family members
in a studio apartment in Queens so it
was super humble as you and you know
obviously my parents are very much my
heroes one because my mom is the
greatest parent of all time and two
because my dad worked his face off and
even though I slept under the same roof
literally every day of my life with my
dad in the first fourteen years of my
life I literally never saw him because
he left at 7 a.m. or 6 a.m. and he came
home at 10 p.m. and he worked seven days
a week how many people here are
immigrants or children of immigrants
raise your hands awesome so this group
that just raised their hands they know
that immigrants in America have
absolutely figured out one of the core
secrets which is you know work your face
off and don't buy dumb [ __ ] and so
that's kind of what my family did for
seven or eight years you know we my dad
wasn't making that much money but a
funny thing happens when you buy nothing
but food at the lowest possible price
and save save save save
and very quickly only six years after
coming to America with a hundred bucks
my dad was able to buy a small liquor
store in New Jersey we moved
Jerzy that is where my entrepreneurial
career began when I was six I had a five
lemonade stand franchise I manipulated
my friends into standing behind the
lemonade all day and that is when I
became obsessed with attention and this
is really interesting as you can see up
here I day trade attention culture and
built businesses at six years old I
would spend my summer days literally
walking up and down the streets of New
Jersey sitting down on the curb watching
cars drive by so that I could figure out
which tree or post was better for me to
put a sign that said lemonade a quarter
that is DNA that's like somebody singing
that's like somebody throwing a pitch
really like that is just pure DNA I
didn't read a Seth Godin book or go over
to Harvard Business School to figure out
that attention was the number one asset
the one thing that combines every person
here from the cameramen back there who
are producing to the industry that is in
this room to me to Mickey to anybody
else that sneaked in the one thing that
fundamentally connects all of us is
before you tell me how great your
product and services you need my
attention so that I listen I am obsessed
with attention I am obsessed with this
device because it has the attention I am
unemotional if it's ruining the kids and
they don't know how to engage or that
you were sad that people go out to
dinner and don't talk to each other
technology does not care about your
feelings and so I as a human may have
some opinions about Parenthood and in
society and privacy as a human but as a
businessman I am unemotional and not
romantic all I do is follow where the
attention is and I figure out how to
story tell in there to create the action
that I desire whether that is to sell a
pair of sneakers or a book or my agency
or whether that's to raise money for the
Crohn's and Colitis foundation because
my brother has it or get my friend
elected mayor it is completely arbitrary
but there is one religion where is the
attention of our consumer and I think
the thing the Delta the most
poor in an exciting thing for me in this
room today is yes there is some
attention of course at a conference if
you set up a booth and yes there is
intention if you spam everybody 24 hours
a day on LinkedIn or cold call or decide
to buy a full-page ad in the
business-to-business magazine that four
people open yes there is some attention
but in 2018 if you do not realize that
that is overpriced attention then you
are vulnerable for the growth of your
business I spend all my time thinking
about overpriced and under priced
attention and what's happening in
culture I navigated from my lemonade
stand to baseball cards because I'm 42
and in 1987 8 9 - 1990 baseball cards
was the culture every kid was buying
them and that was my life I was really
an unusual Eastern European immigrant
that came during that time every one of
my friends every one of my parents
friends kids were straight-a students
because education was they way out if
you go to Instagram literally right now
and look at my account Gary Vee - posts
ago I posted my high school report card
cuz nobody believes me
but I was a straight DNF student
somewhere around fourth grade I realized
that Saturn was not going to impact my
life and I didn't care about it and so
self-awareness is a son of a [ __ ] you
know and and and and honestly besides
health for everybody in this room I wish
you self awareness because once you
understand who you are you can do a lot
of damage all of us suck at a lot of
stuff all of us are good at a lot of
stuff the game is to figure that out
I threw good parenting through
circumstance through who knows really
what got very self-aware very early in
my life and listen at 13 you know listen
it was tough for my friend's parents to
say I was a loser cuz I got these in FS
it wasn't fun for my teachers to say
that I wasn't gonna amount to anything
here was my biggest problem I was 13
years old I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards
I had 47 thousand dollars in cash under
my bed and I wasn't selling weed I
thought I was amazing I turned 14 and
then my dad ruined my life I'm oldest
son first generation born in the old
country that means one thing
14th birthday all weekends and summer
vacations are eliminated I go work in
the liquor store twelve hours a day
bagging ice two bucks an hour I go from
making $3,000 a weekend being the king
to making $24 a weekend
my dad is born in the Soviet Union which
means that he hates his employees which
meant the four foot eleven me going into
that environment was really bad for me
because they hated him back and so it
was you know those two years literally
every weekend every summer vacation my
leisure my child had ended in eighth
grade I kind of had my friends but I
just never saw them outside of school
and so I was old school right I was much
more of a merchant son from the 50s and
40s and 60s just happened to be growing
up in the 80s and 90s and so for two
years I was stuck in the basement I call
those the dark years and then finally my
junior of high school when I turned 17 I
was allowed to come upstairs and then my
life really took a big change I realized
that people collected wine and because I
was so into collecting baseball cards
and those things that became the passion
connector for me and basically going I
went from reading the Beckett baseball
card guide in school 24 hours a day to
reading The Wine Spectator in school 24
hours a day and it ate you know 17 18 I
decided you know his first ball was fun
to get to know my dad even though he was
rough you know it was fun and - it was
the family business beside I was gonna
go into it and in 1993-1994 I thought I
would open up I used to have it in my
mind as I'll open up 1800 of these I
will build the toys-r-us of wine I will
sell the franchise one day by the New
York Jets when some Super Bowls call it
a day
so that was that was basically the plan
at 17 and basically the Jets part is
still in play everything else has
evolved so I you know was a terrible
student I thought I wasn't going to go
to college another thing some of the
kids of immigrants in here know is that
your parents don't know stuff so my mom
came to me February of my senior year
literally 90 days before we graduate and
says to me so what are you doing about
college and I laughed and I said mom
what are you talking about like we
missed it like I didn't take my SATs I
didn't apply for school I have to go to
work in the business I knew my mom would
be embarrassed if I went to a community
college so I knew that was her
kryptonite so I was super pumped I
thought I figured it all out some of you
may have a Soviet mother she looked me
dead in the face and she said you better
figure it out I'm gonna punch you in the
face until you bleed so good so as fate
would have it this is literally how I
went to college I think it's gonna be
interesting to you literally the next
day I get a postcard in the mail in the
mail a postcard like we got mail I went
to go get the mail there's a postcard
from Mount Ida College literally I
filled out my name and my address I sent
it in and that's how I went to college
so this is the college I went to just so
everybody's grounded I'm in my dorm room
freshman year I'm playing Madden 94
dominating by the way and and my friend
runs in and goes you have to come and
see this I finish off my game I go in
and I see seven guys standing around a
computer this is 1994 I have been on a
computer for maybe 15 hours in my life
because I failed typing class in
computer so I never did it I had a word
processor that I was supposed to use I
never did and I'm looking at this
computer and it was the first time I
heard COO couch that whole thing and for
there's you know looking around there's
not that many youngsters how many people
here do not remember the world free
internet raise your hand you're that
young not that you have a bad memory
you're just under 30 raise your hands
okay good not many so for everybody else
we actually remember the world
pre-internet which is crazy
if you think about it now but we lived
it and so you know the first time I saw
the Internet I literally sat there for
four hours watching other people go on
it because it was so crazy a couple
other things that were crazy for the
three youngsters it was $2.99 an hour
from AOL and a minute I don't remember
this I don't know all I remember is that
like it was like $8,000 a month and I
was like I thought it was a good deal
and 17 minutes after I was on the
internet I found my after waiting for
four hours to go on it at like two
o'clock in the morning I found myself on
an AOL bulletin board where people sold
baseball cards that was the moment that
I realized I wasn't gonna open up 1800
liquor stores 15 months later I launched
one of the first three ecommerce wine
businesses in America called
winelibrary.com 18 months later I took
over my dad's business here's where it
starts to matter for you because I
believe in following where the attention
is not where you think the attention is
or how you became successful in the past
I was able to grow my dad's business
that was doing three million dollars a
year on 10% gross profits so 300,000
before expenses my first year marketing
budget was $14,000 for the year in a
five-year window from 1998 to 2003 on
that without raising capital without
getting a credit line on that financial
situation
I built my dad's business from a three
to a sixty million dollar a year
business I did it because of timing I
did it because email had launched and I
thought it was a good idea to email you
wine offers instead of sending you
postcards that cost me a lot of money I
did it because Google AdWords had come
out and I thought it was a good idea to
buy the word of wine for five cents a
click before anybody knew what it was my
entire career what what allows me to be
here today what allows me to dream and
be audacious about owning a professional
football team is very simple I chase
underpriced attention
I chase properly priced attention and I
completely punt overpriced attention
simple I know that everybody in this
room does things for eight to ten hours
a day every day of the day of the week
the month the year on things that no
longer bring as much value as it did six
nine 14 years ago that helped you get to
this point I know that there's somebody
in this room that if they started a B
the B podcast I know that if somebody in
this room who had never thought about
producing content or media if they
started a podcast which they don't even
have the beginnings of a thought of how
to do that right now but the good news
is you literally go to google and you
type in how do I start a podcast I know
that if somebody here started a podcast
for this industry and put out an episode
every week and interviewed a thought
leader in this industry that even though
only 700 to 1500 people would listen to
it because it's obviously very niche in
its content that it would be the
differentiator of growing their business
that it would lead to lead gen that
there are people that they're trying to
chase to get the account that in turn a
year later would be chasing them to be a
guest on the show which then would
inevitably lead to them getting the
business my friends please understand
over the next period of time as I talk
to you about some of these nuances that
I am NOT a technologist that had I not
been in business that I wouldn't want to
have necessarily an Instagram or
snapchat or LinkedIn account it doesn't
come natural to me it's not necessarily
what I want what I want is to sell stuff
what I want is to run a successful
business what I want is to win and to me
if you sit in this room and you do not
realize how extreme the internet
technology revolution actually is you
become vulnerable if you do not
understand that bookstores just happen
to be first that limo services just
happen to be next if you do not
understand that everybody in this room
is vulnerable to technology advances and
that you either
jump on a surfboard and ride this wave
or you face the idea of looking at this
wave coming at you and dealing with the
ramifications to me this is not about
necessarily even when I paint that
analogy the idea that you're gonna go
out of business to me my biggest fear is
people actually how many people grew in
the last year your business has grown in
2017 compared to 2016 raise your hands
raise them high be proud it's awesome
let's actually clap it up for this room
that's awesome one one more time for me
because I want context raise it high how
many people grew from 16 to 17 so I'll
be honest with you that's my biggest
concern when I see a room of 70 or 80%
of the room growing that's usually the
biggest challenge for my passions and
ambition winning in the micro is usually
a tell to complacency to change or
invest or break the patterns that have
gotten you there I get it it doesn't
feel natural when it's working to take a
360 or make a hard turn but that's
exactly the passion I come here today
with which is the following
I believe that everybody in this room is
in the media business I genuinely
believe that everybody here needs to
become the b2b magazine of their
industry that everybody here needs to
put out content on Facebook and LinkedIn
especially on a daily basis I also
believe that 99% of you don't agree with
me and I genuinely believe that I
understand that I I see it every day I
get it but to me the b2b sector with
service providers is exactly the place
where the opportunity lies let me
explain
my career is growing rapidly on one very
basic thesis I give away all my content
for free everything that I know
everything that's working for me I put
out on YouTube and Facebook and LinkedIn
and my email every day for free there is
no mastermind there's no island that I
want you to come to and pay me $50,000
there's no $900 eBook
there's no funnel there's nothing
there's my content it comes out once
every two years I put out a book it's
like 13 bucks on Amazon and we call it a
day there's a couple things that most
people don't understand about this
thesis number one ninety nine percent of
people don't do anything with the
information fundamentally the most
fascinating thing to me about humans is
it's more fun to complain than do right
or it's more fun to paint a narrative in
your mind than do a lot of you in this
room who fear monger technology love
what's going on right now with Facebook
you are thrilled that Mark Zuckerberg is
testifying right now in front of
Congress you know why cuz you're lazy
you love it because you don't want to
take the time to spend a hundred or 200
hours to figure out how to sell stuff
and get clients through Facebook because
it's hard and so you've made a romantic
point of view because your children or
grandchildren didn't talk to you and are
looking at the phone you've started the
subtle path to fear-mongering technology
and I think that's awesome
because for me on the other side I want
you to continue to hate it because
Facebook is simple it's a marketplace if
I'm look if you're trying to reach the
decision-maker at a retail organization
that guy or gal is also the same person
that I want to reach to sell a bottle of
wine or a book to and that space in his
and her Facebook feed is only one space
so that is supply and demand I used to
buy that space four years ago for a
dollar for every thousand impressions
now it's seven the longer you think this
world doesn't exist and you
fear-mongering the longer you don't put
money in the longer I can extract all
the value I've lived this game I'm not a
hero because I took it from three to
fifty million 60 million my dad's
business I actually am a schmuck I
should have spent more on Google I had
it figured out every time you typed in
Cabernet Merlot silver Okemos Napa
Bordeaux I was showing up first
nobody realized it was good real estate
and it was only costing me five or ten
cents a click and I was making between
seven and eighty dollars in profit for
something that was costing me three
dollars to get you through the funnel on
the average of sixty people coming in
one converting I was stupid
I'm being serious with you I stand here
and have passionate about LinkedIn and
Facebook marketing in a b2b environment
today out of regret for what I did from
2002 to 2005 because I should have spent
more it was basic math but I just didn't
understand because I was young in my
career and it just I don't even know how
to explain it to you when it's too good
to be true it's too good to be true
right I'm an immigrant I was cynical I
just didn't I also thought it was
important to do direct mail and local
commercials and magazine that I was
doing it all but in hindsight it was the
great mistake of my career the great
mistake of my career was not spending
more money on Google and I promise you
the great mistake of your accelerated
growth for the 80% that just raised her
hand is not taking advertising on
LinkedIn and Facebook seriously because
you don't think your person is on it
I've heard every guys I've been doing
this for 10 years
I know what your Excuse is gonna be I
can't wait to the Q&A I'm gonna stand
here and want to but Gary my my target
the person is a 63 year old man he's not
on it [ __ ]
of course he's on it who they think is
spreading all the Democratic and
Republican propaganda on Facebook
literally this is my life guys I go to
meetings every day with the biggest CEOs
of the world you know the pep season is
chases the company's CMO CEOs and
literally they scold me for the first 30
minutes that Facebook is ruining our
democracy because you know they know
I've been an advocate of this for a
decade literally this is now have been
three times in the last hundred days I
go to have breakfast it's a 1-hour
breakfast we're there to talk business
but for the first 20 to 40 minutes it
gets completely sidetracked because that
individual wants to scold me Gary you
don't understand Facebook and Twitter is
tearing down the American democracy and
then we spend the last 20 minutes and
they explained to me that Facebook is
not effective in selling lipstick I sit
there and I say do you just
lies that you just told me this platform
is powerful enough to tear down the most
powerful institution in society but then
literally on the other side of your
mouth you told me that it doesn't sell
your product and that TV is better watch
this let's all agree this audience is
not filled with thirteen-year-old
teenage girls right this is a we're old
right world right watch this by show of
hands how many people here now mainly
watch Netflix or Amazon Prime or what is
called an OTT HP on-the-go mainly those
platforms raise your hands actually
please stand up please I mean it I
apologize I know you're lazy but stand
up I want people to see this I want you
if you make do not sit down yet and
honestly if you mainly watch Netflix or
Amazon Prime or Hulu or YouTube guys I
just need everybody look around I have
clients that are spending a t-bill
bab and get up here get up here I want
to make sure all this is my blog you'll
be on YouTube shortly just so vlog real
quick these are old people right I mean
this is 30s and 40s and 50s and 60s and
70s look around literally Jesus 87% of
this audience doesn't even have the
chance to consume a commercial and the
13% that are sitting that watched
Network when a commercial goes on they
grab this eighty billion dollars spent
on commercials in America and nobody and
I mean nobody is watching cool thank you
thank you it is true and what's scary
about that and and here's my thing it is
true and you know what else is true the
tens of billions of dollars that are
spent on banner ads and digital nobody's
clicking and looking at either this is
not an argument about new or old this is
an argument about common sense and
common sense and data are very obvious
on this everybody here
sell a lot more stuff if they take the
hundred hours to learn how to do written
words pictures and videos on Facebook
and LinkedIn and it will fundamentally
change your business because the other
99% of people in here aren't gonna do it
that's it literally if I wasn't
contractually obligated
I would leave right now like literally
literally that's the punchline my
friends what what you know my career
picking it back up on the recall so cool
I'm building the business and then
YouTube comes out YouTube is like a
hundred days old I see it I go cheese I
think this is gonna be big and in
February of 2006 before YouTube was even
one years old I started a wine show on
YouTube it was called Wine Library TV i
sat in front of a camera I had four
bottles of wine and I drank them for
twenty minutes was the best gig I ever
had but something very interesting
happened in episode one and you can go
and see it on YouTube now episode 1 of
Wine Library TV when I started Wine
Library TV when I asked one of my stock
guys to run out to Best Buy to buy a
camera to do the episode I thought I was
on the verge of starting QVC my intent
was camera would be on and I would take
some wines we had in the store and I
would sell them
I'm a Salesman I'm in business right the
light goes on and literally it's funny I
looked at this the other day I can see
it in my I know you know you know
yourself I can see where I realize oh
crap this is gonna be on the internet
forever and if I actually don't love
this wine it's probably a bad idea for
me to say it's good and and I remember
thinking you know how your brain can
think while you're doing something else
literally as I'm doing the episode I'm
thinking about this scenario where
somebody comes up to me in a function
like this and hands me a glass of wine
and says what are you thinking I'm like
oh it's crap and they go AHA you know
you said it was awesome like and then
Dateline showed up and like why'd you
say that was I gonna so so right there
in episode 1 I started kind of actually
giving my opinions luckily the first
episode was this really $200 wine and
they were great but something
weird happened I started reviewing wine
on my show that we sold that I had
relationships with people that took me
into their home in Napa Valley and I
would tell you the American public that
this wine sucked that it was off
balanced that it didn't work and it
caused a real brouhaha in 2006 and seven
in my industry but it taught me
something incredibly important number
one first of all content sells just as
much as advertising that was extremely
new for me and probably anybody a decade
ago I couldn't believe that this was a
show that I was putting out for free
that was distributed for free that had
no hook nothing but people would see me
talk about Valpolicella in the episode
go to the website and buy a different
bellyful of cello or what have you it
was super fascinating number two I just
knew that authenticity mattered and that
transparency was coming and a lot of
what we see with privacy now just was an
inevitable future but then my career
took its biggest turn I wake up one
morning and google buys YouTube for 1.7
billion dollars and I read the article
in The Wall Street Journal and it speaks
about this gentleman who made a ton of
money on a $25,000 angel investment into
Google he made like 10 million bucks and
I said what is that and so actually it's
really funny to tell you this story
literally yesterday I was in The Wall
Street Journal they have a section now
your best and worst investment I told my
best which is Facebook but Google sells
and I realize this talent I have of
understanding consumers and what they're
gonna do email ecommerce you know Google
AdWords YouTube I don't need to use just
for selling more wine I need to figure
out how to do this bigger I'm an angel
investor now which I didn't really
understand what it meant but I googled
it and I learned and within the next 12
months I made my first three investments
and that was Twitter Facebook and Tumblr
so a couple things I'm rich
- I watched from coast-to-coast
something that everybody believed was
small and didn't matter to go and become
the thing that we most fear literally I
in the last decade have lived a life
advocating for a platform that went from
this is not a big deal only my kids use
this in college
- literally it being on the verge of
having to be regulated by the government
because it has too much power that's
black and white and so did all of you
all of you from the day you heard about
Facebook - today
have watched it go from some silly thing
that either you or your younger siblings
or your kids what who cares means
nothing to the CEOs testifying I'm
talking about the biggest if you think
that that platform and LinkedIn and I'll
go back to that in a minute do not have
the ability to affect your business you
are not thinking big enough you're
thinking basic you're making the
judgment on the one guy or gal you call
on you know look you know what you're
doing you're making the judgment on a
focus group of one you call on span at
this retail organization and stand 67
and he still has a piece of [ __ ] flip
phone right what you don't realize is
that stan makes decisions in a million
different ways including the four people
that report to Stan who happen to be 37
and 42 who live on these platforms who
have a ton of influence on Stan's final
decision or a million other things that
can happen so for me the punchline is
very simple we are living through the
greatest shift of attention that the
human race has gone through since the
printing press I'm a historian in my
forementioned report card if you go to a
little instagram after this talk and
look at it you'll see FS everywhere
these everywhere I got four A's in my
entire career
all in Jim and then you'll notice a
couple of bees and they're all in
history and they're in history because
history always tells me the future
everything I believe in right now is
based on my learnings and education
around what happened in America when we
transitioned from the radio to the
television the biggest companies
biggest wealth was created in that
transition because our attention shift
from sitting in the living room and
listening to TV boxing and horse racing
and baseball are number one in America
because that platform of audio was great
for it football and basketball emerged
in the TV era very basic very easy to
understand John F Kennedy loses the
debate on the radio wins it on
television right my friends history will
tell you the future and let me promise
you this fact if you leave with anything
in this talk these platforms are
affecting your business dramatically
more than you realize
in the hidden I don't believe because I
did a lot homework that you're losing
the business is somebody else because
they're effectively out marketing you on
Facebook and LinkedIn I believe that you
could be effectively out marketing
somebody and you're leaving the Delta
you know what's better than growing 18%
growing 50% and this is leaving money
and opportunity on the table because you
haven't made the mental and strategic
decision guys do you know many vendors
give me stuff for free or offer it for
free or highly discounted yeah all day
all day because I produce content like
my refrigeration my like like we just
built out a 50,000 square foot studio in
Long Island City and people I've gotten
so much awareness now with my content
that people are not only offering me the
kitchen supplies in the HVAC and the
painting in the wall not only the
offering of a free I've got companies
offering to pay me to give me the stuff
for free
it's just media
it's just attention they're not Mother
Teresa they don't like me they like the
attention they get from me to who
they're trying to reach if Gary's using
this video company well then I should
too this is very basic it's very hard to
wrap your head around I come from an
immigrant one store retail New Jersey
shop like I get it I grew I spend all my
time and I get thousands of emails a
week from
s/m bees and mid-market businesses from
zero to 50 million I understand a lot of
what I'm talking about is tough to make
the connection point on but I am
convinced that nobody here is confused
that we are now living in this culture
the literally literally the only thing
that's stopping you is typing in words
into YouTube and Google to do the
homework on how I know that people here
can make let's talk about being media
versus being a salesperson I know people
here can talk about their product and
service as a whole not specifically
their product they how many people here
have been business for 20 years or more
in what they do raise your hands raise
them the utter expertise that is sitting
in your head of pattern recognition and
things to look out for I mean do you
understand that if you made how many
people here are a vendor trying to get
to somebody here and sell their product
to raise your hands just curious raise
them high please amazing do you
understand that for the majority of this
room that if you made what is called a
SlideShare it's a deck it's owned by
LinkedIn and it's just down the
education of understanding what's
happening in our world then if you made
a slide of the value of what your thing
is like there's not I don't know every
nook and cranny but let me give an
example if you're a window supplier
let's just go there that comes natural
to me if your windows supplier if you
made a slide that said the value for
retail operations to transition or
replace their windows every seven years
if you titled at that the value the
disproportion now doing a little
copywriter the disproportionate ROI of
switching out your window fixtures every
seven years at retail if you make that
deck and then in that deck you make 13
14 15 pictures written words a deck a
presentation that was more as if you
were a media company or a b2b magazine
not as a sales pitch it's just general
information there is no your phone
number at the end and if you buy now
nothing
no right hook just jabs just content
that if you made the disproportion ROI
of changing out your window fixtures at
retail every seven years Dec and you put
that on LinkedIn and you spent stick
with me here 1500 to 2000 dollars
targeting employees of people that are
in your funnel in your market the people
that you're trying to reach you would be
flabbergasted at the conversion rate of
those kind of executions I know this
because I invest a lot in b2b SAS
businesses and service providers and
have made a lot of money in the exits
and the going public's of these
companies because of the
disproportionate nature of their
marketing that has been so much more
progressive but if you think I think
that that's what's happening back home
on a normal day that people are sitting
around and saying hey let's start a
podcast or hey let's make a deck on
SlideShare and run ads on LinkedIn I'm
aware that we're in a sales driven
relationship shake your hand driven
business I get it that's exactly why
what I'm talking about matters it's
where the Delta sits when everybody's
doing the same thing there's only so
much value in that execution when you're
next to your competitor at the booth
when you're at this event when you're
doing the golf outing when you're buying
the ad and the b2b magazine when you're
selling Direct Mail when you have a
sales team it's all the same stuff
becomes disproportionally commoditized
over time and as you know it becomes a
race to the bottom on the dollars so I
think it's an incredible time to become
a practitioner look a lot of you have
huge opinions a lot of headline readers
in this room about how this marketing
works a lot of people here have opinions
on how Facebook works for your business
yet you've never run a single facebook
ad in your life a lot of you have a ton
of opinions on our Facebook works for
your business yet you don't even have a
Facebook account so a lot of opinions
that lack the reality but I will tell
you this the people in this room who
wrap their head around what I'm talking
about and I'm gonna take it down a notch
I'm gonna take it down a notch to bring
value to this room
I believe everybody in this room how
many people here have a business that's
doing over a million dollars a year
raise your hand that every person that
just raised their hands should hire
somebody for forty to fifty thousand
dollars a year to produce content and
distribute it on LinkedIn and Facebook
for their business for one year just to
see what it feels like here's the scary
part when I hear that if you hire
blindly like you know what you're gonna
do oh yeah maybe I should hire my niece
she's 23 if you do the cliche thing of
hiring a young person who uses social
media to hook up not to sell crap and
you know nothing about it you won't know
how to judge it thus you become
vulnerable so before you hire the person
for forty to sixty thousand a year to do
this and try it for one year because if
your business is doing over a million a
year and it's 2018 and you live in our
society you're smart enough to realize
that risk is worth it because even if
you sell nothing it's good to check the
box and know it doesn't work
it's an ROI positive event if it doesn't
work it keeps you from debating if
there's any truth in my conversation you
yourself as the manager c-suite or owner
have to become educated in this and let
me say another thing this is just life
you have the benefit of being in
business and being an event like this
please for your own self I just have
something that you need to wrap your
head around this technology thing it's
not going back like you do understand
everything like you do understand that
this is this computer in my pocket that
I'm holding up right now is more
powerful than the computer that Ronald
Reagan had to run the free world you do
understand that you also do understand
that this computer that's more powerful
than what Ronald Reagan had to run the
free world is gonna look like a pager in
a decade how many people here are
retiring in the next ten years and I
don't mean you're gonna
[ __ ] and then you know by an island I
mean you're just really old
then you need to retire how many people
by show of hands retiring in the next
ten years
alright let's first clap it up because
that's the most hands I've ever seen
this is the oldest event ever for the
ninety five percent of you that did not
raise your hand you will be a operator
in business in a decade and if you don't
know what I'm talking about right now
what's LinkedIn and Facebook you were a
deep [ __ ] when it comes to machine
learning
they are crypto blockchain there's a
million things coming that is like you
running the Boston Marathon tomorrow yet
you've done nothing to prepare please
please I know we're having fun it's
light-hearted we're laughing this is
awesome I'm enjoying it
I don't even want to get to the Q&A when
I just keep doing my Chris Rock thing up
here but but please let's take a quick
step back and understand how big the
stakes are I spoke at the 2012 for 11
taxi and limo convention I was an early
investor in uber I walked on stage I
said listen to me yes I have a lot to
gain for uber success but I'm looking at
human beings and it's not fun to think
about what the ramifications of that is
I've already made enough money I don't
need to I called my dad's friends in LA
who owned black car services anybody
ever live in LA or live in LA a couple
of people so you may know in the late
70s when my you know family and friends
immigrated yes we went to New York in LA
and all the Russian guys originally rode
cabs and then they eventually owned all
the black car services I called when
uber started gaining trench traction in
San Francisco I called aka
when they came and visited we had mean I
talked to my dad's friend modoch and
Nikolai and Vladimir and all these
freaking cliche Russian names
and I said to them listen to me this is
a problem and they looked at me and they
laughed and here's why they laughed they
came to this country with four dollars
and over the course of 30 years they
pulled themselves up from nothing to
owning these multi-million dollar
businesses and they were 62 and 57 and
like in that place and they laughed at
me
and I said you know I literally can hear
in my ear okay okay and heavy Russian
accent you know but English which was
interesting because I don't think I can
speak Russian well enough which is very
disrespectful nonetheless they go okay
one more time you're saying that they're
gonna take the phone hit a button and
the limo is gonna literally laughed at
me and drank eight more liters of vodka
here's where it doesn't get funny
because it's real life 36 months later
those three core gentlemen that I'm
thinking about its businesses were worth
a dime on the dollar that they were
worth three years earlier
uber collapsed their business it wasn't
pretty
it was carnage technology is gonna eat
everything I don't know your business is
well enough to know where that plays in
but this is basic this is the biggest
force in our society and we need to ride
that wave not have it crush us period
you have to figure out how to make
technology your teammate not your rival
you can't fear monger it and you can't
put your head in the sand you're gonna
be hearing about robots that are gonna
kill us which is gonna be true so good
news we're fairly old we'll probably
miss it but our kids are finished I'm
not kidding and so please wrap your head
around how big this is
and please start going to the two
biggest search engines in the world I
don't know how you learn either google
and read how do I use Facebook to sell
HVAC units to retail establishments
enter or you may learn like me cuz I'm
not good at reading go to YouTube the
number two search engine in the world
how do I sell HVAC units to retail enter
and watch a video
while you run read I don't care how you
consume content but if one of you if one
of you heed my advice this morning and
get to action if ten of you who were
pooh-poohing this whole thing this
morning when you got your Starbucks are
listening to a businessman not a
futurist not an author not a student
somebody who makes money somebody who
helps other people make money
businessman if you hear me loud and
clear if you do something about it we've
accomplished what I was hoping to this
morning I wish you health and I
appreciate your time
stuff so we have a few minutes for
questions we have two floor mics do we
have any questions from the floor is
someone coming up to the mics okay great
Matthew good afternoon hey brother
what's your name
Matthew Whelan hey Matt what's your
feelings on releasing duplication of
content at the same time on multiple
platforms or kind of spacing it out and
kind of moving in different directions
you know I'm not worried about the
spacing out because somebody might be on
LinkedIn somebody might be on Instagram
somebody may be on YouTube I'm worried
about the context okay the same picture
- the same person acts differently on
Pinterest Instagram Facebook Twitter
because your psychology is different the
average 47 year old female in this room
when she's on Pinterest she's in an
aspiration to buy buying window shopping
when she's on Facebook she's keeping up
with her world she's in a different
mindset so your content has to have
different words or different angles to
it people distribute across all of them
for efficiency because they think of it
as direct mail and things of that nature
but they're under estimating the
psychology of the person when they're
consuming it so you'll see on my Twitter
Facebook and you know Instagram similar
stuff but you'll notice that the copy
that associates with it is very
different and that's what I have to do
with it including when you're writing
something about hey do you like I put
out a lot of stuff of like I just don't
understand why people hate their job
meaning we just spent way too much time
at work and I know you have to put a
roof over your head but my big thing is
like sell your house or live more humbly
and get a job that pays less because
being miserable 63% of your time is a
bad strategy period when I put out that
content on Sunday night and Monday
morning and Friday afternoon
it does 30,000 times better because
that's when you're in that mindset and
so you know a big one for b2b I love
pounding the day after Labor Day
literally the Tuesday to Friday after
Labor Day is some of the places where I
make the most money because
businesspeople feel the tension of being
checked out in August and they feel like
they have to move quickly and make some
decisions
psychology matters my friend okay thanks
Matthew
Troy Troy Troy
right how do you see the transition of
voice in this space like Alexa and
Google home and all that playing into
the content marketing so it's no
question the place that I'm most bullish
I've stopped investing for the last
three years because after making a lot
of money and the best thing is you guys
know everybody now has a startup
and and just like I was tired of meeting
every person who's got that um I'm the
uber of donuts does that mean like so
but I'm gonna get back into investing
again because all the apps that are
gonna be built on top of Alexa are the
next Spotify Instagram ways I think it's
gonna change our lives I think you're
gonna be stunned how quickly you're
gonna have in a lecture of Google home
or Apple pod in your bedroom in your
bathroom it's you guys have to
understand the reason there are 60 year
old men in here texting right is because
it's faster no matter how much we hate
technology or fear it speed is something
we are addicted to do you know why you
don't care about privacy because you're
willing to give it up for speed it's
it's it's a tough thing for humans to
grapple with but it's how we act it's
faster for me to say Alexa what's my
Tuesday look like or order bananas or
you know help me get that vendor I mean
I think it's a huge huge deal but it's
extremely early I think of it as like
when we were first discovering land
right you come over like there's the
people that see the berry bush and you
know they don't know if it's poison
enough and you know the guy goes eat in
it I got [ __ ] and they died you know and
the next one's like Oh delicious
raspberries you know that's what's gonna
happen on alexa over the next three to
four years there's a lot of people that
are gonna spend time and money and lose
but then there's gonna be people that
buy all of Manhattan for a dollar but
the content you see transitioning over I
think humans have consumed content in
written word pictures videos and audio
forever and that will continue to change
and there's Epson
close to me before anybody here thinks
about what their Alexis strategy is I
would say much like high elevated and
went from selling wine to becoming
America's wine guy can you go from
selling whatever the hell you sell to
being the b2b leader of thinking around
that genre I think everybody here needs
a weekly or monthly podcast that's you
understand b2b is the best yours
thinking podcast can have an 88
listeners but that can have a five
million dollar impact so I think I'm
obsessed with voice I would argue
everybody here you should be thinking
about producing a podcast first there's
there's an app I'm not an investor I
pushed it a lots of people think that's
why I'm hedging it's called anchor dot F
M anchor dot F M literally you can
record your podcast on your phone hit
one button and it distributed it does
everything for you
you should look into it if you're
debating this sir okay I'm sorry go
ahead go ahead
good morning I've been Piper from the
piper companies and there's I want to
just take a little bit of a different
piece what one thing that happened this
morning please that really kind of blew
me away
is I've been in my own business for a
long long time after that I've kind of
had a little bit of a path like yours
where I became a speaker and trainer as
well understood what the first question
you asked is does anybody here know me
and I was blown away by how many people
didn't have any idea of who you were
right
in my world you know the way that I stay
on the top of things is speaking and
training is by following people like you
I'm gonna see you and Tony in Fort
Lauderdale next month in yep so I stay
on top of all that and to me I see such
a great importance in personal and
professional development so forget about
the understand stuff for the moment - I
want to know if you can just give us
something to take away that I think
would be incredible on that how
important that really is to every single
person here I appreciate it my big thing
is that's a funny area for me right
like I think personal development and
and motivation can get really blurry and
Hux
at the same token I genuinely believe
that optimism and offense is the only
option right so for me I you know I I
think the one thing that I would say
that everybody is I don't understand the
ROI of fear dwelling or complaining
right I just I can't figure it out
the only people listening to your
problems are other losers I mean it
right now if you think you're
complaining or you got it comes natural
to you just think for 40 seconds who the
person that you talk to the most about
it it's your miserable mom it's it's
your sister it's always that so I highly
recommend I'm a big believer in the
auditing your circle and really thinking
about who you're spending time with I
just want to remind everybody you find
what you're looking for my friends it's
very easy right now to find negativity
the problem is it's equally easy to find
positivity right mainstream media is
making a lot of money selling fear and
negativity let me just and I see time is
up and up you can email me at Gary at
vaynermedia or DM me on Instagram for
the four of you let me just say one
thing that I'm completely fascinated by
and this is not political this is just
life I can't stop thinking about how
easy it is for somebody that wants to
inflict harm to get into a car and drive
into people it's the easiest move of all
time there is no stopping anybody ever
for getting into a car and driving into
a crowded area it is unstoppable just I
just want everybody actually understand
that I then think why the hell does that
not happen in every major city every
single day I'm a data guy even though
I'm not and I'm an actions guy and so I
just think listen the math is on our
side this is the greatest era of all
time for everything that you're
complaining about right taxes race me to
all sorts of stuff that we need to
address and I'm happy that we're
addressing it and we're
addressing it because the Internet I
hope everybody understands that the only
reason me to and all the good stuff
that's happening in our societies
happening is because three old white
guys don't control the media anymore
I just want everybody to wrap their head
around that number two the data is on
our side you know what's worse than like
unemployment or this is a the black
plague the black plague is worse right
like our grandparents and our great like
do you understand the things we complain
about like my uber is just missed me and
is going around the block again or or or
oh you son of a [ __ ]
I ordered almond milk not soy milk at
Starbucks like like I don't know about
you guys but I live life listening I
travel a lot I listen like the stuff we
complain about or we think is bad would
literally make our
great-great-grandfather slice our
throats it is time that we put what's
happening right now in perspective this
is the greatest era to ever be alive
because of modern medicine and the macro
of where we live and my thought on this
is if you listened to everything I
talked about for the last hour if you
think that's bad you were on defense in
your life and if you think it's
phenomenal you're on offense and you
need to make a decision because you're
either on offense or defense do not
trick yourself into thinking you're in
the middle
no wait one look what do you want one
last question and then that for the
three other individuals Gary oh you'll
be on me on Instagram Gary Vee I'll
answer a little good so one last
question and then we'll wrap how are you
I'm good so my question is if you're new
into having yes yes how content hashtags
you know collaborations and the best
part of all spending money on ads it's
so funny people put organic growth on a
pedestal why if the advertising is
underpriced why not take advantage of it
so I'll go through it slowly one more
time because I want people to win every
time you post something at this point I
think everybody knows what a hashtag is
if you add hashtags that's a
discoverability on these platforms right
Instagram and Twitter use it more
LinkedIn and Facebook use it less but
they still work right collaborations
inviting you know the reason if you how
many people here listen to podcasts
right so if you notice look very careful
a lot of the biggest podcasts have
guests why because they use the guest
star power to build audience the thing
I'm probably most proud of is I don't
have guests you know like I've built
just through the content but
collaborations bringing people on to
co-author or interview them think about
what your audience wants
it's empathy empathy is the secret to
all of this if you actually care about
the audience instead of your own
following count and your business you'll
get what you actually want make sense
but but no question for this industry
the ads the ads are underpriced I don't
notice to tell you you can target
individuals you're looking for locations
you're looking for again all this
hysteria of Cambridge analytic is cuz it
works it works
so the ads and and then again it's
Google how do I run LinkedIn at I mean
it's all there the reason I don't talk I
don't have a whiteboard or slides is the
blocking and tackling is free on Google
the reason I spent my time on the talk
is you're not gonna block and tackle
until you understand the strategic and
philosophic
reason this is happening and what the
whitespace is that is if you want to
understand what I just did I got to get
you to actually understand this is real
for real for real for real not hahaha
then you can I mean this guy's on his
phone right now he literally can go to
google type in just just so you know I
just watch you I'm pumped I'm like he's
hustling forget what I'm doing the
information the information is on the
Internet it cost zero dollars and zero
cents the thing that's stopping people
is fear lack of education and ideology
all three bad ideas when it comes to
business awesome let's give it up for
Gary Vee thank you thank you thank you
so much thank you
that's so nice back that's good yeah
that's got enjoyed aha
thank you guys hey guys thank you right
back here
[Music]